dès les premières secondes la tension
est palpable
jean charest et pierre poilievre sont
les deux seuls candidats ne pas se
serrer la main
comme à son habitude celui qui est
souvent décrit comme le meneur dans la
course reproche à l'ancien premier
ministre du québec d'être libéral
il de mal comprendre la cause des
camionneurs à ottawa qu'il a soutenu
jean charest réplique qui accuse pierre
poilievre d'avoir appuyé des blocages
d'illégaux mais sur paul yeves
and olick embarquée nombreux dans la
foule hue le candidat québécois
et signale clairement où ils se rangent
quand il est question du convoi mais
député de la région de tahoua maintient
la pression sur son principal adversaire
lui demande avec insistance combien
d'argent il a reçu de la compagnie croit
oui à l'époque la détention des deux
maiko
jean charest ne répond pas étant plutôt
de mettre pierre poilievre sur la
sellette lui reproche de dire une chose
et son contraire sur la loi 21 pierre
sur pierre de taille de
la candidate de la droite sociale leslie
n'diaye accuse elle aussi pierre
poilievre de tergiverser cette fois ci
sur l'enjeu de l'avortement sida the
wanted leur avait promis plus tôt cette
semaine en pleine tempête aux états unis
le député a pris plusieurs heures avant
de préciser qu'il n'allait pas ouvrir le
débat sur la question
et une heure et demie d'échangés
acrimonieux chaque candidat repart de
son côté encore une fois aucune poignée
de main entre les deux présumés meneurs
le fossé qui les sépare ne pourrait être
plus évident ici laurence martin radio
canada